what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing
of life why the hell are we here
ryan johnson we've been talking about
brains and studying brains and
you had this very eloquent way of
describing life on earth as uh
as an optimization problem uh of uh
the cost of intelligence going to zero
at first through the evolutionary
process and then eventually
through building uh through our
technology building
more and more intelligent systems you
ever ask yourself
why is doing that yeah i think the
answer to this question again the
information value is more in the mirror
it provides of that person which is a
representation
of the technological social political
context of the time
so if you asked this question a hundred
years ago you would get a certain answer
that reflects that time period same
thing would be true over a thousand
years ago
it's rare it's difficult for a person to
pull themselves out of their contextual
awareness
and offer a truly original response and
so
knowing that i am contextually
influenced by the situation that i am
a mirror for our reality i would say
that in this moment
i think the real game going
on is
that in evolution
built a system of scaffolding
intelligence that produced us
we are now building intelligent systems
that are scaffolding
higher dimensional intelligence this is
developing
more robust systems of intelligence
in doing in that process with the cost
going to zero
then the meaning of life becomes
goal alignment which is the negotiation
of our conscious and unconscious
existence
and then i'd say the third thing is if
we're thinking that we want to be
explorers is
our technological progress is getting to
a point where
we could aspirationally say
we want to figure out what is really
going on
really going on because does any of this
really make sense
now we may be 100 200 500 1 000 years
away from being able to
poke away out of whatever is is going on
but it's interesting that we could even
state an aspiration
to say we want to poke at this question
but i'd say
in this moment of time the meaning of
life
is that we can build a future state
of existence that is more fantastic than
anything we could ever imagine the
striving
for something more amazing
and that defies expectations
that we would consider bewildering
and all the things that that that's and
and i guess the last thing
if there's multiple meanings of life it
would be infinite games you know james
karst wrote the book
finite games infinite games the only
game
to play right now is to keep playing the
game
and so this goes back to the algorithm
of the lex algorithm
of diet soda and brisket and pursuing
the passion i'm what i'm suggesting is
there is a
there's a moment here where we can
contemplate playing infinite games
therefore it may make sense to err on
the side of making sure
one is in a situation to be plain
infinite games if that
opportunity arises so just the landscape
of possibilities changing very very fast
and therefore
our old algorithms of how we might
assess risk assessment and what things
we might pursue and why
those assumptions may fall away very
quickly
well i think i speak for a lot of people
when i say that
the game you mr brian johnson have been
playing
is quite incredible thank you so much
for talking today thanks lex
you